last Tuesday the unthinkable happened
Hilary lost the election
you have to accept the fact that Trump
will be our next president or you can
live in blissful denial like I do
by taking she won a day by tomorrow she
wanna date contains powerful truth
inhibitors that redirect your brains
narrow chemical pathway and tricks you
into thinking that Hillary won it all
turning your dread and despair and to
hope and joy and she wanted a vitamins
is not just for women it's for Mexicans
african-americans environmentalists
beauty pageant contestants and Billy
Bush honey I mean he didn't have all
that baggage with the emails and he
would have brought the Millennials and
that could have helped to flip Ohio plus
people who protest voted for Jill Stein
here in droves
[Music]
and after your foot rubber maybe some
oral sex she won a day vitamins it's
your only hope
you